I am with Simon Willison Zeppelin
experts hello Simon Thompson it up now
so in 1910 the airship America made the
first ever attempt at a cross Atlantic
crossing and on the way into the airship
one of the engineers scooped up a stray
cat who've been living in the hangar and
the cat laid they christen the cat kiddo
put him on the airship said this would
be great we'll take him along he can be
the ship's mascot kiddo was not keen on
this idea at all kicked a real stink and
so once they got out of the Atlantic
they transmitted the first ever radio
message from an aircraft and the message
was Roy come and fetch this goddamn cat
so they sent a lifeboat out to fetch the
cat the cat was put in a bag lowered
down towards low fast real choppy water
the cat was furious the waves are too
choppy they couldn't rescue me and I'm
the hoisting back onboard it's okay
we're taking with the cat then settle
down obviously deciding that the airship
was a lot better than the back and um
and you know settled into the flight
they quickly discovered the he was the
perfect companion because cats are
better than manometers the cat would get
grumpy before they hit bad weather way
before any of their instruments could
detect him that was a fine but they were
trying to cross the Atlantic 33 hours in
they the the airship broke possibly
because of sand that they picked up
earlier
they couldn't stir it they found
themselves adrift they eventually
spotted a Royal Mail ship out at sea
managed to signal SOS to them got
rescued by it and I think they made the
first ever aerial SOS call as well and
they were rescued along with the cat the
airship floated off and was never seen
again the Royal Mail shipping back to
New York where kiddo
was put on display in the window over
fancy department store with a diamond
necklace on as the as a celebrity cat
and he really did live the left rest of
his life out on the farm Simon thank you
very much that is something you might
not have known thank you